I couldn't help but notice that your it
was just I didn't know working with your
partner Darren collaborated on so what
makes him so great
I mean his point of view is this
artistic he's just brilliant he's
incredibly instinctive
what makes Jennifer so great I don't
know what makes him great maybe was her
parents maybe it was the Kentucky water
I have no idea but she's like the
once-in-a-generation talent and just
like a whirlwind and hurricane and an
earthquake and a and a thunderstorm of
talent you know working with partner and
the best of circumstances can be tricky
by the intense journey as this
the other work relationship was that
tricky not at all I know it was very
very relaxed she's the type of back that
it turns off the intensity when she's
not shooting and then flips it on when
she needs it and so between action and
cut she's the character and then when
you call cut she's Jennifer Lawrence
again said you had an amazing ability to
kind of like be intense and be there for
moral shock is it pretty much the only
way that you could survive a journey of
purgatory yeah I had to stay and like
the torturing feeling or state of mind
it would have want to be an accurate
just go do something else
your friend Emma stores also a chance to
hang out what would be C we've we've had
a chance to say hi but our schedules
around offices we were gonna fly
tomorrow together until we realized I
would be horrible idea you know but I I
think we're gonna hang out of the New
York wait to see her boobies
[Music]